[Música]
Hola son las 8 de la noche en Bogotá a
las 10 en Buenos Aires y Montevideo yo
Santiago aristía y les doy la bienvenida
a esta segunda hora de información en
directo a América Estos son algunos de
los hechos más destacados de la jornada
el expresidente de Brasil Jair bolsonaro
no podrá ejercer cargos públicos durante
8 años el ultraderista fue hallado
culpable del delito de abuso de poder
por el tribunal federal electoral esta
decisión le impide presentarse a las
elecciones presidenciales de 2026
polémica en Venezuela la contraloría
general confirmó que la opositora María
Corina Machado inscrita para participar
en las primarias de octubre se encuentra
inhabilitada para competir por un cargo
de elección popular por un total de 15
años Machado lidera las encuestas y
calificó como inútil la medida
Francia moviliza a 45.000 agentes en la
cuarta noche consecutiva de disturbios y
protestas que se acuden al país desde la
muerte de nahell un joven de 17 años a
quien un policía le disparó la violencia
en las protestas sigue escalando y el
gobierno adoptó una línea más dura
y hoy en directo a vamos a ir hasta
Miami porque a partir de este sábado
primero de julio entra en vigor la nueva
ley impulsada por el gobernador
republicano ron de santis contra la
inmigración irregular la medida genera
polémica y para entenderlo conectaremos
con nuestro corresponsal en Miami
Anthony bercy y en deportes hablamos de
ciclismo porque este primero de julio
comienza la edición número 110 del Tour
de Francia La segunda gran vuelta dentro
del calendario de la unión ciclista
internacional en su Crónica deportiva
Luis Méndez Zurich nos trae todos los
detalles de la primera etapa y también
quienes podrían ser los protagonistas de
la competencia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
comenzamos en Brasil porque el Tribunal
Superior electoral condenó al
expresidente Jair bolsonaro por abuso de
poder con cinco votos a favor y dos en
contra bolsonaro quedó de esta manera
inhabilitado para ejercer cargos
públicos durante ocho años una decisión
que le impedirá presentarse para las
elecciones presidenciales de 2026
Gabriel con todos los detalles
es una sentencia histórica el
expresidente Israel bolsonaro está
oficialmente inhabilitado por 8 años los
siete jueces del tribunal superior
electoral se pronunciaron este viernes
sobre su caso y cinco de ellos lo
reconocieron culpable de abuso de poder
el ponente votó a favor de descartar las
cuestiones preliminares y sobre el fondo
conceder parcialmente la solicitud de
condena del primer acusado Jair Mesías
bolsonaro por la práctica de abuso de
poder político y uso indebido de los
medios de comunicación en las elecciones
de 2022 declarándolo inelegible por 8
años
el ex presidente fue condenado por haber
deslegitimado el sistema electoral
especialmente durante una reunión con
Embajadores en el Palacio presidencial
en la cual atacó al sistema devoto
electrónico a sólo tres meses de las
elecciones de 2022 también fue
reconocido culpable de uso debido de los
medios de comunicación ya que transmitió
dicho evento en la televisión pública el
expresidente denunció su condena y
anunció que apelará la decisión
Hoy es un día emblemático para mí como
el 6 de septiembre de 2018 cuando me
apuñalaron Hoy recibí una puñalada por
la espalda con esta decisión no es a
Yair Mesías bolsonaro a quien le dieron
esta puñalada sino a la democracia
bolso no podrá presentarse en las
próximas elecciones presidenciales
previstas para 2026 sin embargo el ex
jefe de estado de extrema derecha ya
avisó que podría apoyar a la eventual
candidatura de su esposa Michelle
bolsonaro para las presidenciales Jair
bolsonaro se enfrenta a otra decena de
investigaciones judiciales que podrían
ponerlo tras las rejas
hay polémica en Venezuela la contraloría
general confirmó este viernes que la
opositora María Corina Machado inscrita
para participar en las primarias del
próximo mes de octubre previas por
supuesto a las elecciones presidenciales
de 2024 se encuentra inhabilitada para
competir por un cargo de elección
popular por un total de 15 años Machado
recordemos lidera las encuestas para las
primarias y para profundizar en esta
información nos acompaña te ignora
Hernández ella es secretaria política
nacional del partido veinte en Venezuela
de la opositora María Corina Machado de
ignora Hernández Muchísimas gracias por
su presencia en France 24 en español
Gracias a ustedes por la invitación No
gracias a ustedes una vez más bueno para
ayudar a comprender esta inhabilitación
cuéntenos cuando fue impuesta Con qué
motivo y cuál es su vigencia
bueno en las últimas horas en Venezuela
hemos visto las acciones desesperadas
erráticas y descolocadas de un sistema
oproso que se sabe perdedor y que ha
acudido a estrategias con órganos
apéndices de este sistema que no
contempla división de poderes con su
vocación totalitaria y han impuesto
medidas como estrategia para callar la
voz ciudadana que se expresa
mayoritariamente a favor de nuestra
líder María Corina Machado le reitero la
pregunta perdón Cuándo fue impuesta esta
medida Cuál es su vigencia
es que tal como te señalé fue nos
acabamos de enterar de ella en las
últimas horas Entonces no tiene una Data
que yo te pueda decir específicamente me
imagino que son tareas estrategias que
siempre están latentes en un régimen con
esta mentalidad pero las últimas 24
horas específicamente ayer este se dio a
conocer esta noticia cuéntenos tienen
planes desde su partido opositor para
seguir disputando la presidencia del
país en caso de que Machado
efectivamente no pueda presentarse para
disputar las primarias
en mi organización política nuestro Plan
B es el plan a nosotros luchamos por
conquistar la libertad de Venezuela y
ese deseo mayoritario se expresa en las
calles en cada una de las
concentraciones que acompañan la
ciudadanía a María Corina Machado de
manera que en este momento solamente nos
mantenemos en igualdad de situación para
nosotros no ha cambiado nada esta medida
no nos sorprende y le decimos al mundo y
por supuesto al régimen del pacto que
impere en Venezuela que el único que
habilita e inhabilita líderes para que
lo gobiernen en el ciudadano y en esta
ocasión el pueblo venezolano le ha dicho
claramente las calles a Nicolás Maduro
que no lo queremos Ya ahora la
contraloría tiene legitimidad para esto
o cree Bueno sería necesario para que el
gobierno logre con lo que usted denuncie
no que es su objetivo sería necesario
que se abra un proceso ante la justicia
en Venezuela no hay Estado de derecho no
hay división de poderes y todos los
órganos tribunal supremo de Justicia
asamblea nacional electa por el sistema
de Nicolás maduro y este apéndice que es
la contraloría del estado que la USA
como un un órgano para perseguir para
inhabilitar Sencillamente todos están al
margen de la ley ninguno goza de
legitimidad y por eso insistimos en
Venezuela se ha convocado un proceso de
elección Primaria para este veintidós de
octubre donde el pueblo venezolano puede
escoger puede legitimar y puede decidir
quién está habilitado para gobernarle de
manera que a la ciudadanía al elector
venezolano y al ciudadano Al único que
nos debemos y desconocemos totalmente
estas medidas de este régimen que no
busca más que en su estado de pánico a
callar la decisión de un pueblo que ha
decidido ser libre continuaremos Podemos
esperar entonces que me haya dado
continúe con sus actos de campaña
estamos en campaña estamos en la calle y
estamos llevando el mensaje de libertad
No desde ahora desde hace mucho tiempo
de manera pues que esta medida de
inhabilitación en contra de María Corina
machada es una medida inútil que carece
de toda legitimidad porque insistimos la
legitimidad le da al pueblo venezolano y
ya está gritando Libertad en las calles
del lado de María Corina Machado esta
medida es Sencillamente una estrategia
desesperada de un régimen que se sabe
Derrotado estamos con la ciudadanía Y a
ella nos debemos ignora Hernández
Muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
24 en español
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes por la
invitación gracias a ustedes avanzamos
con más noticias Colombia y Venezuela
instalaron la denominada comisión de
vecindad e integración un mecanismo que
supone un nuevo paso en el
restablecimiento de las relaciones entre
ambos países los cancilleres de Colombia
Álvaro Leiva y el de Venezuela Iván Hill
se reunieron este viernes en Bogotá en
la primera visita del representante de
exteriores de Caracas al país en cinco
años las partes firmaron una declaración
con la que buscarán responder de forma
coordinada a la atención y desarrollo en
las zonas de frontera la verdad es que
nunca ha debido existir darse una
ruptura
yo creo que va a haber un reclamo
histórico
un reclamo histórico haber suspendido
haber desconocido
a la República bolivariana de Venezuela
es algo absolutamente insólito
de tal forma que lo que estamos haciendo
hoy
que es aquello de regresar a la buena
vecindad a la integración el dejar atrás
ese error y la Corte Suprema de Estados
Unidos bloqueó hoy el plan del gobierno
de Joe biden que buscaba perdonar 430
mil millones de dólares en pagos
atrasados de préstamos académicos se
trata de una promesa de campaña del
presidente quien lamentó esta decisión
el pronunciamiento se da un día después
de que este mismo órgano judicial
cancelará el acceso de las minorías a
las universidades ampliamos desde
Washington con nuestro corresponsal
Cristóbal Vázquez
la Corte Suprema dictaminó este viernes
que la administración de biden había
excedido Su autoridad con su plan de
eliminar más de 400 mil millones de
dólares en deuda estudiantil frustrando
así las esperanzas de decenas de
millones de prestatarios estudiantiles e
imponiendo nuevas restricciones al poder
ejecutivo según datos del gobierno más
de 45 millones de personas en todo el
país deben uno coma seis billones en
préstamos federales estudiantiles y la
propuesta de cancelación de la deuda
anunciada por billete hace un año habría
sido uno de los decretos más costosos en
la historia del país sin embargo el
presidente dijo desde la casa blanca que
su administración Tratará una nueva
alternativa se trata de Cancelar
préstamos estudiantiles bajo una nueva
ley esta ley se trata de la ley de
educación superior de 1965 que contiene
una disposición que otorga al secretario
de educación Miguel Cardona la autoridad
de comprometer renunciar o liberar
cualquier derecho título reclamo es
decir la capacidad de perdonar deuda
estudiantil para millones de estudiantes
recordemos que esta decisión se da un
día después de que la Corte Suprema haya
limitado la acción afirmativa que le
daba la posibilidad a jóvenes de
minorías negras y latinas entrar a
universidades de calidad en Estados
Unidos
continuamos en Estados Unidos donde la
población
lgbtiq más sufrió un revés en sus
derechos si es que la Corte Suprema
dictaminó este viernes que el derecho
constitucional a la libertad de
expresión permite que ciertas empresas
se nieguen a brindar servicios para
bodas entre personas del mismo sexo la
corte de mayoría conservadora falló a
favor de la diseñadora web Smith quien
citó sus creencias cristianas para
negarse a realizar trabajos para
matrimonios igualitarios según el fallo
la ley de Colorado que prohíbe la
discriminación basada en la orientación
sexual obligarías a crear un discurso en
el que ella no cree y eso sería una
violación de la constitución
Francia moviliza a 45.000 agentes en la
cuarta noche consecutiva de disturbios y
protestas que se acuden al país desde la
muerte de un joven de 17 años aquí en un
policía le disparó en la ciudad de
provocándole la muerte en la ciudad
norteña del varios grupos de
manifestantes se reunieron en las
principales carreteras donde se
desplegaron grandes cantidades de
gendarmes y policías antidisturbios en
la capital París la policía registró a
varias personas mientras que en nantech
lugar de tiroteo al Joven se acumulan
filas de camionetas policiales la
violencia urbana sigue escalando y para
resolver la crisis y calmar a la
población El Ejecutivo francés adoptó
una línea más dura ampliamos en el
siguiente informe
durante la jornada del viernes el
gobierno francés emitió una serie de
declaraciones en un intento por resolver
la crisis en primer lugar reforzando el
dispositivo de seguridad para la noche
fueron movilizados 45,000 policías
frente a los 40.000 del día anterior
volvía a llamar a los policías y
gendarmes de su permiso movilice más
unidades de la redada la abrí y el gign
también hemos decidido utilizar
vehículos blindados lanza aguas de la
gendarmería nacional y helicópteros que
ya se utilizaron ayer y evitaron muchas
tragedias
como los disturbios se extendieron la
víspera a varias ciudades hasta entonces
indemness los autobuses y trans vías se
paralizaron en todo el país a partir de
las nueve de la noche por el momento sin
embargo no se impusieron toques de queda
ni estados de excepción medidas
reclamadas por la derecha y la extrema
derecha frente a manifestantes a veces
muy jóvenes el presidente de la
república apela a la responsabilidad de
sus padres
de los detenidos anoche eran jóvenes a
veces muy jóvenes y es responsabilidad
de los padres mantenerlos en casa no es
el papel de la República ocupar su lugar
el gobierno también apunta a las redes
sociales donde desde hace cuatro días se
publican masivamente vídeos de
enfrentamientos con la policía el
ministro de Justicia pidió a las
plataformas que retiren los contenidos
más sensibles
Más allá de una reacción de seguridad
Todavía no se ha anunciado ninguna
reforma de la policía a pesar de que ese
sea el foco de la colega de los jóvenes
[Aplausos]